Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In June 2020, OpenAI published an incredible
AI-based technique by the name Image-GPT.
The problem here was simple to understand, but
nearly impossible to actually do: so here goes,
we give it an incomplete image, and we ask
the AI to fill in the missing pixels. That is,
of course, an immensely difficult task, because
these images may depict any part of the world
around us. It would have to know a great deal
about our world to be able to continue the images,
so how well did it do? Let’s have a look!
This is undoubtedly a cat. But look! See that
white part that is just starting? The interesting
part has been sneakily cut out of the image. What
could that be? A piece of paper? Something else?
Now, let’s leave the dirty work to the machine and
ask it to finish it! Oh yeah, that makes sense.
Now, even better, let’s have a look at this
water droplet example too. We humans, know that
since we see the remnants of ripples over there
too, there must be a splash, but the question
is - does the AI know that? Oh yes, yes it
does! Amazing! And the true image for reference.
But wait a second. If Image GPT could understand
that this is a splash, and finish the image like
this, then, here is an absolutely insane idea. If
a machine can understand that this is a splash,
could it, maybe, not only finish the
photo, but make a video out of it? Yes,
that is indeed an absolutely insane idea, we
like those around here. So, what do you think,
is this a reasonable question,
or is this still science fiction?
Well, let’s have a look at what this new
learning-based method does when looking at
such an image. It would do something
very similar to what we would do,
look at the image, estimate the direction of
the motion, recognize that these ripples should
probably travel outwards, and based on the fact
that we’ve seen many splashes in our lives, if
we had the artistic skill, we could surely fill in
something similar. So, can the machine do it too?
And now, hold on to your papers, because
this technique does exactly that.
Whoa! Please meet Eulerian Motion Synthesis.
And it not only works amazingly well,
but look at the output video. It even
loops perfectly. Yum yum yum, I love it!
And it works mostly on fluids and smoke.
I like that! I like that a lot, because
fluids and smoke have difficult, but predictable
motion. That is an excellent combination for us,
especially given that you see plenty
of those simulations on this channel,
so if you are a long-time Fellow Scholar,
you already have a keen eye for them.
Here are a few example images, paired
with the synthesized motion fields,
these define the trajectory of
each pixel, or in other words,
regions that the AI thinks should be animated
and how it thinks should be animated.
Now, it gets better, I have found three things
that I did not expect to work, but was
pleasantly surprised that they did.
One, reflections, kind of work.
Two, fire. Kind of works.
And now, if you have been holding on to your
papers so far, now, squeeze that paper, because
here comes the best one, three, my beard works
too. Yes, you heard it right. Now, first things
first, this is not any kind of beard, this is an
algorithmic beard that was made by an AI, and now,
it is animated as if it were a piece of
fluid using a different AI. Of course,
this is not supposed to be a correct result,
just a happy accident, but in any case, this
sounds like something straight out of a science
fiction movie. I also like how this has a nice
Obi-Wan Kenobi quality to it. Loving it. Thank you
very much to my friend Oliver Wang and the authors
for being so kind and generating these results
only for us. That is a huge honor, thank you.
This previous work is from 2019 and creates
high-quality motion, but, has a limited
understanding of the scene itself. And of course,
let’s see how the new method fares in these cases.
Oh yeah, this is a huge leap forward.
And what I like even better here is that new
research techniques often provide different
tradeoffs than previous methods, but are rarely
strictly better than them. In other words,
competing techniques usually do some things better
and some things worse than their predecessors…but
not this. Look, this is so much better across
the board. That is such a rare sight. Amazing.
Now, of course, not even this technique is
perfect. For example, this part of the image
should have been animated, but remains stationary.
Also, even though it did well with reflections,
refraction is a tougher nut to crack. Finally,
thin geometry also still remains a challenge.
But this was one paper that made the impossible
possible, and just think about what we will
be able to do, two more papers down the
line. My goodness. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!